EPISODE.
YEAR.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US.
♪
>> Laura: WELCOME TO THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE FROM
WASHINGTON.
A HUGE SHOW TONIGHT.
WITH YOU.
A FAMOUS LAWYER WAS
SOLICITING MONEY TO PAY
AGAINST CANDIDATE DONALD
TRUMP DURING THE 2016
CAMPAIGN.
GETTING PAID TO ACCUSE THE
CANDIDATE.
STORIES?
WE'LL DISCUSS IT ALL WITH
ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
I WILL ALSO TALK TO WHITE
HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY SARAH
SANDERS ABOUT THE CONSTANT
BARRAGE OF MEDIA ATTACKS.
SOME AGAINST HER PERSONALLY
AND THE PRESIDENT.
BUT, FIRST, THE DEMOCRATS ME
TOO SUICIDE MISSION.
OKAY.
FEMALE POLITICIANS AND
TAKE THIS BECAUSE SOME DAY,
MAYBE, MEN MIGHT DECIDE TO
TURN THE TABLES ON THEM AND
START LAUNCHING THEIR OWN
MAYBE IT'S CALLED #MEN TOO
MOMENT WITH WILD DECADES OLD
COMPLAINT AGAINST WOMEN IN
POSITIONS OF POWER.
YOU DON'T THINK IT COULD
HAPPEN.
IT THE FIRST TRAGEDY IS.
AFTER THE KANSAS CITY STAR
ASKED HER ABOUT ALLEGATIONS
IN A 12-YEAR-OLD LAWSUIT.
THE SUIT CLAIMED RAMSEY
SEXUALLY HARASSED AND
RETALIATED AGAINST A MALE
SUBORDINATE WHO HAD REJECTED
HER ADVANCES.
THE CASE REACHED A
THAT THE CASE WAS DISMISSED
AFTER MEDIATION BACK IN
2006.
LOOK, PEOPLE SETTLE SUITS
ALL THE TIME.
THEY SETTLE THEM FOR THINGS
THAT AREN'T TRUE AS WELL
BECAUSE THEY ARE JUST A
NUISANCE AND THEY WOULD
RATHER NOT BOTHER THEM.
BUT DROP OUT OF THE RACE
MORE THAN A DECADE LATER FOR
THIS?
I THINK THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
BUT, THIS IS THE CLIMATE
THAT DEMOCRATS HAVE CREATED.
IT IS A TRAP THAT THEY
THEMSELVES ARE NOW FALLING
INTO.
BELIEVE ME I PROBABLY AGREE
WITH THAT CANDIDATE ON
NOTHING.
HE SHE IS A FAVORITE OF
EMILY'S LIST.
I'M SURE SHE AND I WOULDN'T
AGREE ON MOST ISSUES BUT
THAT SITUATION IS APPALLING.
NANCY PELOSI AND THE REST OF
THE NEW LIBERAL MORE RATTLE
BRIGADE ON CAPITOL HILL ARE
FEEDING ON THEIR OWN
MEMBERS.
THEY HAVE OPENED UP AN
ETHICS PROBE INTO A NEVADA
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN
REUBEN COULD YOUEN OVER
NOW, PELOSI AND OTHERS HAVE
ASKED COULD YOUEN
CUKED COULD YOUEN
CUEMD COULD YOUEN
CUEM TCOULD YOUEN
CUEM TOOULD YOUEN
CUEM TO SLD YOUEN
CUEM TO STE YOUEN
CUEM TO STEPYOUEN
CUEM TO STEP DUEN
CUEM TO STEP DOWN.
IS HE REFUSING.
HE VOWS TO CLAIM HIS NAME.
ANOTHER DEMOCRAT.
THE WITCH-HUNT CONTINUES.
THE ALLEGATIONS AGAINST HIM
A YEAR AGO.
HE SAID THEY LOOKED INTO
THEM.
THEY DIDN'T FIND ANYTHING
THEY CONTINUED INVESTING
MILLIONS IN MY CONTAIN.
CAMPAIGNED FOR ME.
WE INVITED HIM ON THE SHOW
TONIGHT BUT SADLY HE
DECLINED.
MY FRIENDS, THIS ME TOO
MADNESS IS SPINNING
DANGEROUSLY OUT OF CONTROL.
AND I THINK THE PEOPLE GET
IT.
HERE'S SOME OF MY LISTENERS
THIS HAS GONE TO THE EXTREME
AND THEY HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING TO STOP THIS.
>> I'M VERY SENSITIVE TO ANY
#THAT HAS BECOME ALMOST A
FAD.
>> FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE,
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN REALLY
ABUSED, SEXUALLY ABUSED, ARE
SO UPSET ABOUT THIS
MOVEMENT, THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT BECAUSE THEY ARE
MAKING A JOKE OUT OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVE REALLY BEEN ABUSED.
>> Laura: BY THE WAY THE
PHONE LINES TODAY WERE
JAMMED WITH FEMALE CALLERS.
SPEAKING OF JOKES, NOW
DEMOCRATS ARE CALLING FOR
THE PUT TO RESIGN OVER
MISCONDUCT ALLEGATIONS, YOU
BUT AS "THE WASHINGTON POST"
POINTED OUT THIS MORNING,
THE DEMOCRATS MAY BE
OVERPLAYING THEIR HAND AHEAD
OF 2018 AND 2020.
THIS IS THE WAY I LOOK AT
IT.
THE LEFT IN THEIR BLIND RAGE
AGAINST TRUMP ARE UNABLE TO
SEAT OBVIOUS.
THEIR NEAR CONSTANT
DEMONIZATION OF TRUMP IS
STARTING TO WEAR A LITTLE
THIN AND I THINK IT COULD
END UP BACK FIRING BIG TIME.
THINK ABOUT IT.
AFTER TAX REFORM IS PASSED,
THE ECONOMY CONTINUES TO
GROW, AND MORE AMERICANS ARE
ABLE TO KEEP MORE OF THEIR
ACCUSATIONS, PARTISAN LEAKS
AND IDENTITY POLITICS REALLY
END UP HAVING?
ACTIVISTS IN THE DONOR CLASS
REALLY HAVE THE APPETITE FOR
THE GROWING CALLS OF TRUMP'S
RESIGNATION ON THESE OLD
ALLEGATIONS?
SMACK DAB IN THE MIDDLE OF
SINCE REAGAN?
I DOUBT IT.
ESPECIALLY NOW THAT WE'RE
LEARNING THAT WOMEN WERE
BEING OFFERED CASH TO TELL
THEIR TELLS OF ALLEGED
MISCONDUCT BY TRUMP.
WHAT A CROCK THIS ENTIRE
THING IS.
OH, IN THIS SMALL, I WOULD
OUT TO EVERYBODY IN THE
MEDIA.
WATCH THE CURRENT COURSE YOU
HAVE CHARTED LEST YOUR OWN
BOATS GET SWAMPED BY THE
WAVES YOU CREATE.
YOUR REPORTING ON THE
SO-CALLED RUSSIAN COLLUSION
HAS BEEN AS BIASED AND
MISGUIDED AS THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION ITSELF.
YOU NEED TO OFFER MORE THAN
24/7 DEMONIZATION OF OUR
PRESIDENT THROUGH LEAKS FROM
OBAMA AND CLINTON PARTISANS
OR FROM OLD ACCUSERS WHOSE
STORIES WERE ALREADY HEARD
BEFORE ELECTION DAY.
OR MAYBE LOOK INTO HOW SMALL
BUSINESS OMNIPOTENT MICHELLE
IS SKYROCKETING DUER TO THE
PRESIDENT'S SLASHING OF
ONEROUS GROWTH-KILLING
REGULATIONS?
AND BY THE WAY, ANOTHER
QUESTION.
SO MANY OF YOU IN THE MEDIA
TO STORIES ABOUT THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION?
YOU KNOW, WHERE ARE YOUR
FOIA REQUESTS.
OR MAYBE YOU ONLY DIG DEEP
WHEN IT CAN HURT THE